hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for everything anime
and manga so long as that anime and or
manga is hunt hunter otherwise we seem
to have difficulty making videos but
today we are here once again to focus on
one of my greatest loves in all of media
hunter hunter but instead of seeing its
well-earned praises as per usual i'd
actually like to talk about some things
that tend to really annoy me about hunt
hunter because it is a really strange
series that i both loved and hated when
going through it for the first time and
while i will say that those things i
dislike to become much more clear and
easier to accept with every reread or
re-watch there are still features about
it today that i do have difficulty
reconciling hunter hunter is not perfect
absolutely nowhere near it and in fact
the way i think of it is that hunter
hunter is one of the world's largest but
uncut and unrefined gems it holds
massive value
but not in a particularly clean way and
that by the way is not necessarily a bad
thing
nothing i'm going to be discussing here
is objectively bad
they're just things that do annoy me
personally but at the same time i will
begrudgingly admit that they are
essential
in making hunter hunter what it is just
like how you dear viewer are essentially
making this channel what it is by
subscribing to the new world review and
thus receiving regular hunt hunter
content uploaded straight into your
youtube feed so please do join our
association and let's keep this series
alive during the
darkest of hiatuses um before i really
get into things i just want to say that
i will not be mentioning the art when
talking about any detracting features of
hunter hunter the manga art is probably
one of the most commonly brought up
which is usually only done so by people
who have read online scans of the weekly
releases
published in shonen junk which to be
fair they can be glorified storyboards
however most of if not all of these
issues are fixed in the volume releases
so i have nothing to complain about
there because
it's no longer an issue amazing i'm not
so sure i can say the same for
everything
else and with that smooth aft transition
my first big annoyance with hunter
hunter is very generally
togashi's story structure so despite
working in the often wanky and
narratively questionable world of
theater i actually really tend to enjoy
classically structured narratives in
particular the super simple concepts
of setup and payoff and there are many
times in hunter hunter where things are
painstakingly set up only to be
abandoned with no payoff or then there
are times when payoff occurs with no
setup sometimes they even operate in
conjunction
to one another for example during york
new city we spend a lot of time
following milikey's journey and in a
typical story we would be setting him up
to be a major part of the greed island
arc as either an antagonist or an ally
because that is how setup and payoff
works
instead what we experience is the setup
and then abandonment of this entire
story thread with milikey and examples
of this are very common in hunt hunter
where you could remove entire subplots
that are never resolved and the series
itself would probably feel no different
and my wife refers to this
in her reviews as the practice of
pansing which basically means togashi
making the story up as he goes
which means he will set up certain
elements and then decide how to use them
later down the line
rather than planning them in advance
which does lead to some very interesting
stuff but it also means that
more often than not a lot of setup
pieces don't fit very nicely in the
overall puzzle meaning that tagashi is
forced to throw them out usually rather
unceremoniously which isn't to say that
all of this is accidental and i will say
that togashi does quite often engage in
deliberate subversion by setting
something up with the intention of not
paying it off like the final phase of
the hunter exam where he laid out the
structure of an entire tournament
only to effectively conclude both it and
the entire arc right after the first
fight and in fact come to think of it
almost every arc in the series ends with
a super jarring and sudden halt like
greed island where the finale took place
in the form of a delightful quiz or the
zeldic family arc which ended with
killerwork just casually
leaving the estate when the setup seemed
like it was headed towards more extended
conflict and due to this it can leave
viewers or readers with a feeling of
many arcs being underexplored like pabst
heaven's arena which introduces concepts
like floor masters and battle olympia
only to have our main characters
completely ignore them which is fun and
i think a great metaphor for tagashi
being too distracted with his own
desires to pay attention to generally
accepted story structure and at this
point i really do want to emphasize that
there is no right or wrong way to tell a
story and i'm not saying that togashi is
doing things wrong here
definitely not however there are
certainly more efficient ways than
others to tell stories and togashi lands
on the less efficient side of that scale
meaning that there is a lot of time and
energy invested into things that don't
provide narrative profit which i think
hunt hunter can suffer quite a bit from
on your second or third read or watch
through because you know what is and
what is not going to be relevant with
all of this said though the panting
strategy is very high risk but also
high reward because it leads to a
feeling of complete unpredictability
where a strictly plotted series can
become easy to read well in advance
because you can see the structure being
built and eventually if you have enough
foundation you'll be able to picture the
house however with togashi it's almost
like watching a magician he distracts
you with certain elements whilst
preparing others to hit you within the
shadows so it's a style of storytelling
that is something i both love and hate
but hunter hunter simply would not be
what it is today
without it now my next general dislike
is very much related to this idea it's
actually a knock-on effect of the
panting style which is presented in the
frequency of vanishing and
under-explored characters
once again in a plotted story everything
is designed with a purpose and if a
character is introduced then ideally
they will have a purpose
and additionally if they are major
characters then they would assume that
they have some sort of arc to follow
over the course of the story and this
sort of thing can be really tricky to
pull off when you don't plan too far in
advance which you can see
very clearly in hunter hunter where
every new arc introduces a large band of
new faces who have varying degrees of
relevance and then after the conclusion
of the arc they are for the most part
never to be seen again because we don't
really plan that far ahead now the
elephant in the room here is obviously
leoria he is the standout example
because he was most certainly created
with the intention of being a series
mainstay but instead togashi either ran
out of ways to keep him in the mix or
simply didn't want to because his focus
evolved and thus slayario had no place
in a rather
incredible proportion of hunter hunter
and while i do understand that it is a
bit annoying because i invested time
into larrio and i grew to really like
him so his absence was very felt
but he is far from the only example hunt
hunter is also full of characters who
were just there sort of for the sake of
being there
sometimes with maybe arc specific roles
and then they just vanish into the ether
and i think a great example of this
would be
zepio this man exists almost exclusively
to explain the process of various types
of auctions
a subplot that never really actually
goes anywhere because eventually we
abandon the whole idea of participating
in the auction which leaves up here with
very little purpose in this world and
rather fittingly the last thing we see
of him
is being useless and defeated on the
floor of the hunter exam in a plotted
story
zeppiel would either have been
instrumental in getting gone and killed
a copy of greed island or he would have
not existed at all instead we have this
strange middle ground approach where a
surprising amount of characters fall
into and i do want to say that these are
not forgotten characters as many will
claim that would imply that togashi
accidentally stopped including them i
would actually like to give togashi more
credit and say that they were purposely
abandoned because there was simply
nothing else to do with them and another
random example would be guarano gorenu
has shockingly little purpose other than
to exist and fill a slot in a game
several slots actually via nen beast but
other than that he
i why i don't know why he exists and i
don't
care either i mean i like gaureno but i
i feel like i don't really know anything
about him and furthermore i don't
necessarily want to he's just there and
then he's not
now this idea does have its advantages
though because as much as i prefer
characters with a grand purpose what
this does is create a more realistic
impression of the hunt hunter world to
illustrate we have individuals like wing
who are incredibly important to a
singular section of story and then they
appear maybe a couple of times in
irrelevant capacities afterwards and i
actually really like that we leave wing
and zushi behind to do their own thing
while we continue with hunter hunter and
i would say the same for karapika
biski the hunter association at large
and yes even laeria which is
contradictory to how i start at this
point but that's why it's conflicting i
both love and hate togashi's willingness
to let characters go in favor of
introducing new ones whose inevitable
fate is also
to disappear in a weird way it makes the
world feel so much richer because we
have that expansive breadth of
characters to work with but their
implementation or lack thereof does irk
me quite a bit
which also kind of leads into my third
big gripe which is that i honestly don't
feel like i truly understand the world
of hunter hunter the thing about the
first two points introducing unexplored
concepts or vanishing characters is that
it leads to a shallow overall picture of
this world and not only
that but the very nature of this planet
or whatever it is seems to change with
every arc the hunter exam
painted this world as a highly dangerous
almost magical place whereby after
leaving the safety of whale island
anything goes
and this idea is then immediately
contrasted by an arc that takes place in
a civilized metropolis with no hints of
supernatural or bizarre happenings
outside of secret menus these ideas
could not be more of a stark contrast
and it paints a very jagged picture of
the world and looking at a map doesn't
actually help me reconcile the hunt
hunter world either
firstly because so many well-known
locations aren't even identified on the
map for example i can't tell you where
whale island is or meteor city or the
luxo province where the kurt clan once
lived i can't tell you where any of
those things are they could be quite
literally
anywhere meanwhile in a very
inconsistent nature i can give you the
exact locations of every stage of the
hunter exam they're all right here on
unnamed continent number three which is
very specific but also frustratingly
vague i really don't like that i know
exactly
where some things are and i know nothing
about where other things are and even
the things that i know where are i don't
like that i don't know the name of the
continent that they're on and i also
think the series does a very
questionable job of differentiating
between some major locations like the
hunter association headquarters we just
got shown a miscellaneous city and if
you're not really paying attention to
the series at this point you just go huh
that's york new city because that's the
only city i know of but it's not the
association headquarters is in swadani
city which is located on unnamed
continent number four and this is also
where heaven's arena is although once
again heaven's arena is in a completely
different
unnamed city on an unnamed continent
which is like three metropolises that
are mostly only differentiated by one
central building otherwise aesthetically
culturally and just generally
atmospherically they all feel like the
same place and i get that stuff like
this won't annoy everyone and most
people probably don't care whatsoever
but i personally like having an internal
compass for the world i'm invested in
stuff like game of thrones would be a
beautiful example because i always know
exactly where i am in relation to
everything else because the map makes
sense and isn't just a flipped world map
with arbitrary designations but maps
aren't even the key thing because even
in a series with no maps like one piece
i still feel like i more or less know
where i am at any given point for
example right now we're on wano which i
can't point to exactly on a map but i
can tell you that it's right here in the
new world which is sandwiched by the red
line on two sides as well as north and
west blue on the other it's not overly
specific but it's a good general enough
idea and to be fair sometimes hunter
hunt does really well in this respect
like the locations of ngl and escorto
during the chimera ant arc they are
geographically remarkable planned and
placeable i always know where i am and
what sort of culture i'm involved in
during the chimera ant arc
meanwhile if we're on whale islands
though i can't tell you where that is
which means i have no
compass in operation and that annoys me
i really wish more effort was given to
actually detailing this world because
right now we've been told of this
magical dark continent
which is endlessly fascinating but at
the same time i feel like we're heading
there leaving the vast majority of this
human realm completely unexplored so
i don't know i just wish the series was
more consistent with caring about the
world itself but that would require more
plotting which would mean togashi
adopting an entirely different mechanism
of storycrafting so i will take the
shaky world in exchange for the
fantastic work we do get this is in no
way a deal breaker for me in fact
nothing i've mentioned here today is
which is odd because basically what i've
said when you think about it is that in
hunter hunter what annoys me is the
story the characters and the world
you know just the complete narrative
trifecta togashi does all of these basic
elements in very strange ways which more
often than not do work to the advantage
of hunt hunter but in a very unrefined
way which to put into a positive term
would be raw hunter hunter is a glimpse
into tagashi's raw consciousness
whatever or whoever he's interested in
at the time he will put on page
sometimes those stories and characters
will lead absolutely nowhere but that's
also a nice touch of tangible reality
injected into hunt hunter because very
often in real life endeavours lead
nowhere and we lose track of the people
around us
leading us to discover new people and
new paths forward horus on a manga
hunter hunter is very reflective of life
which means that it can be an
unsatisfying story because in many ways
it follows the whims of reality much
more so than its nature as a story and i
both love and hate that but what i will
say is that it never delves too far into
either of those areas
togashi in an effort that can only be
described as somehow
straddles that line just perfectly
enough to make hunter hunter one of the
most unique experiences
in all of media but what do you guys
think please do leave your thoughts in
the comments below or even join my
discord server and if you're keen for
some more hunt on to content then please
do go and check out some of my other
videos or even subscribe to the channel
for regular hunt under glory delivered
straight into your youtube feed but for
now this has been the new world review
and i'll see you next time